[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment
hey guys from the very first season we
have no net gain Theresa no King Robert
Baratheon as Ned Stark recognized it at
the moment he laid his eyes on him just
like on the show gain Theresa no King
Robert in the books as well however the
series also provided quite a few clues
leading to the possibility that ginjury
is not just Roberts bastard but rather a
legitimate sign of King Robert and Queen
Cersei a clue number one comes from the
second episode of the very first season
from the conversation between Cersei
Lannister and Catelyn Stark
Cersei visits Catelyn who is setting
vigil for bran Cersei tells Kathleen
that her first child a beautiful
black-haired boy died because of a fever
but his theory ginjuries a black haired
beauty Sundancer subscribe to Kathleen
and second episode of the very first
season as she said he had died of a
fever a lot of you're saying that Cersei
might have simply lied and manipulated
Kathleen to get on her good side but
it's definitely not the case because a
few episodes later there's a scene with
Circe and Robert are discussing their
marriage and Cersei tells him that the
start of their marriage she truly loved
him even after their first boy died for
quite a while so it's definitely true
Robert and Cersei had a black-haired
shoe Baratheon child the clothes number
two and three comes from a conversation
between Orion ginjury and arias ginjury
about his matter the only thing he
remembered was Korea look here the same
you already told to his father which is
the clue number two but this time Ginji
also mentioned that his mother worked in
a tavern which would be the clue number
three then we also have a scene image
search they remember sky she used to
disguise herself as a tavern management
she had a secret meetings with Jaime
do you think it's a coincidence that
gage remembers his yellow hair matter
who he said looked like some tavern
wench
while Cersei on the other hand said
herself that she was dressing as a one
to avoid other people recognizing her
well it certainly might be a coincidence
but having in mind that this is Game of
Thrones the series in which almost every
spoken word has a meaning there might be
something more and an actor who plays
ginjury it seems to be supporting this
as well
a few days ago an actor shared his
thoughts about his topic he said I was
most curious as to what we might find
out
dangerous parentage obviously we know
that he was the best heard of Robert
Baratheon but who might his murder
happen an actor who plays gantry wanders
and continues with there's a line in
season one and the first scene you ever
see a ginjury where he's looking to net
and he's asked about his matter and he
says he doesn't remember much about her
at all other than the fact that she had
yellow hair and she would sing to him
it's one of those things where you go do
they usually write lines that don't mean
anything or lines that seem to have
significance that are never just again I
was kind of intrigued to see what that
might mean and what impact it might have
on gingers cloud politically as I was
saying Game of Thrones the series in
which almost every spoken word has a
meaning there might be something more
and an actor who plays ganger seems to
be supporting or even hinting something
the next close supporting this theory is
more of a shadow for sharing than a clue
and it comes from my comment section on
observing Game of Thrones fan says I
like this theory like I said for the
show only there's more evidence for it
when the Brotherhood finds our ginjury
and hot pie in season 3 the archer says
what's lurking behind that wall a lion a
wolf just a dirty little cupboard thing
ginjury the lion
arya the wolf and poor hope by the dirty
little cupboard thing whatever that
means that's a great catch jenji might
be a Baratheon a stag but in this year
he's also lain esterline as I said every
great theory that turned out to be true
like John being the son of Lena in
Rhaegar have clothes hints and for
Sherri here and throughout the series
and it seems to be the most subtle hint
regarding interest to parentage let's
see what other clues the hints are
supporting a theory image ginger is not
a bastard but rather a legitimate son of
King Robert and Queen Cersei just like
netted Stannis also recognized that
ginjuries Robert's son as soon as he
laid his eyes on him upon arriving at
Dragonstone Stannis briefly looked over
ginjury and confirmed that he's
obviously Robert's son looking just like
he did at that age this matches with
Cersei statement that her black hair
Beauty son looked just like Robert you
might wonder why would search to give up
on her firstborn but the answer is very
simple
Cersei has not loved Robert ever since
their wedding night so she decided to
send a boy away as soon as he was born
so the rightful heir to the throne would
be the child of her and Jaime on as
assertion that she always hated Robert
Cersei responded with quoting him here
him I worshipped him every girl in some
Kingdoms dreamed of him but he was mine
by oath and when I finally saw him on
our wedding day in the Sept of Baelor
lean and fierce and black-bearded it was
the happiest moment of my life and that
night he crawled on top of me stinking
of wine and did what I did well he could
do it was pretty my ear Lyanna your
sister was a corpse I was a living girl
he loved her more than me this hurts his
statement alone says it so how much
Cersei hated Robert which eventually
resulted in him being killed by Circe's
intrigues she did not love Robert and
did not want to raise his son as an heir
of the throne so but his theory she gave
a vague injuried secret and lie about
his death
Cersei with Jamie's help replaced the
real baby who would begin G with some
let's call it ordinary lowborn baby
then they poisoned that lowborn boy
causing his death having in mind that
the fever caused child's death Cersei
probably use the same poison Petyr
Baelish analyze the rain used to kill
Jon Arryn the one that causes fever and
results with death recall that in the
dance with dragons first claims to have
switched regulars some it another baby
so infant swaps have happened before I'm
sure most of you are wondering how could
Cersei and Jaime manage to do all that
without being noticed by Robert
Baratheon after all sir she mentions
that Robert was present when their son's
body was taken away and every come to
the clue number 4 so how could a
surgicenter living child away without
her husband noticing this was very
simple to manage since Robert never
attended any of search - albert's
asserts he stated herself Robert would
always go hunting when she was about to
give birth and when he will return
Cersei will present him with a baby and
he will present her with a stag's head
with Robert away hunting Cersei and
Jaime could have easily replaced her son
with her poison clove horn boy I'm also
wondering if Jon Arryn who visited Ginji
a few times before his death actually
found out that Ginter is the first and
true born son of his dear friend King
Robert Baratheon what if the
conversation between Cersei and Jaime
and just general ministers expressed
concern for their lives in case Jon told
the truth Robert was the truth about its
first son and only true born son
could it be that Cersei and Jaime were
worried that Jon might have told someone
the truth about her firstborn child
rather than the truth about her
incestuous relationship with Jaime
that's definitely the case in my opinion
pay attention how in the scene Jaime
only mentions that he inserts it would
be executed if Robert found out the
truth
wouldn't it be them and all three of
their children that will be executed if
Lord the reign father the truth about
their incestuous relationship
long story short Ned Stark thought he
found out the same truth Lord Arryn did
but he might have been wrong as I
believe the most important truth the
John who was the truth about ginjury it
was also raise a question about Lord
Aaron's death which we all know was
orchestrated by Littlefinger what if
Petyr Baelish killed the hand of the
king of course beside the fact that it
gave him an opportunity to marry Liza
who at the time he's already been
manipulating it but also to prevent Lord
Tyrion to tell the truth about games
with Robert but why would have a little
finger even done that what good did it
bring to him in this theory well if Lord
Arryn managed to tell King Robert about
his only true and eldest son he would
not have brought Peter chance to put the
Seven Kingdoms in the state of chaos
from which he personally benefited it
wouldn't have brought him a chance to
set of the war between the lions and
voles and it would not bring him a
chance to manipulate Ned Stark which
resulted just as he planned with the war
if Florida reign he told to King Robert
about ginjury Robert would have executed
Cersei and Jaime Lannister and would
have still been alive Ginji would have
been his heir Lord Arryn would not have
been killed and that Stark would not
have become the hand of the king and the
Seven Kingdoms would not have been in a
state of chaos which would not have
brought any success and benefit a little
finger then we come to the clue number
five Cersei recalls that she never
visited her lost child in his script
which seems very odd also searched they
never mentioned the child's name which
could be a deliberate move on the
showrunners we have to keep his identity
a secret it's also interesting how
ginjury grew up in the slums of flea
bottom and it managed to land a job at
the most prestigious armor in King's
Landing which could be the clue number
six it's said that when he was old
enough and unknown highborn person pay
his apprentice fee so he could learn to
be a blacksmith
Ginji then took up work as an apprentice
blacksmith under montt forging high-end
armor and weapons for the Lannisters
having in mind that Robert had not even
known of his existence
the rich highborn person was helping
injury in my opinion it was his mother
herself Cersei Lannister searched his
love for her bloodline combined with her
hatred for Robert and unconditional love
for her children made her give a Roberts
child read
having killed so she could help pure
lynnster children that would be heirs to
the throne I've already spoken about
this theory a few times on his channel
and every time there's more and more
closing hints with an actor who plays
Ganges seemingly hinting there's far
more we are yet to learn about Ganges
parentage let me know in the comment
section down below if you think injury
might be searched this blue haired son
she claims died shortly after birth
judging by all those cool hints and
proof there's a huge possibility that
ginjury is not just a bastard but rather
true born in firstborn son of King
Robert Baratheon and Queen Cersei
Lannister be aware that this is a theory
for the TV show only not for the books
ing being Cersei son certainly it's not
possible in the books since the little
dark-haired boy that starts the gave
birth during the show does not exist in
the books also in the senior game she
gets legitimized by Danny did you notice
Jamie's face upon hearing injuries
Robert Baratheon son it looked like he
was fingering out the entire thing could
Ginji be that black-haired son of sir
said that she claims died of a fever
please let me know your thoughts about
this theory in the comment section down
below also stay tuned for season 8
episode 5 video that will be published
in a few hours in that very um ring is
some leaked photos from King's Landing
as well as the preview breakdown and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace